so if we doing the C game where he's
he's trying to hit me in the chest right
I'm going to
stick um and then he'll try to get off
of it and I have to follow right so you
always have a
stick and follow to back to stick okay
you're always doing that if he's
doing the mount reversal of whatever
kind he's going to want to PO Ure up
right
okay so you're going to have to come
around and I'm going to stick to him and
if I can I'll keep the adhesion if I can
I'll follow okay and so as he goes one
two we'll go slower here okay and as he
starts to go if I can keep this arm off
of The Ground by following it then then
you're going to have your
work okay so that's going to be our
drill he does
whatever I pick which arm I want and
that's the arm I follow right into it I
don't know if you po that so make sure
you're able to walk
around he goes whatever arm I can stick
to
that's the arm I
work
okay here we
go keep's
going take which arm I want here it is
here okay I keep that arm and my my
first thing is like don't don't
smell this leverage okay he's strong
enough and he's grounded enough he I
can't do that okay so my first thing
that I do is go this way I go sideways
back I'm here I push this way okay then
you have him tilted he's going to want
to stay stand up and that's when you
move out of the way
okay if he doesn't stand up you'll keep
taking him that
[Music]
way so don't smell the instant
technique boom this
way then out from under him out from
under him try to get the Shoulder on the
ground so you attack the
shoulder
so what does alpha M him
mean here I'm going to move out don't
roll
back I move out from under
him this
way okay right so his shoulder falls on
the ground all right so if we're doing
katama go
down and
remember this is uh UD gami okay so this
is this is what you're doing here this
angle with downward on the scapula
mechanism and it goes from the elbow
forward that's what you're
doing so you do it here
different okay do it here
different
here down
down hold shoulder moves
forward so as we go in the technique
coming around that's what I'm looking
for so right now his shoulder is not on
the ground that's why I move out of the
way and now his shoulders on the ground
and my elbow is going to crank back and
down and then this whole thing moves
towards him okay don't start spitting
the arm around
don't drop it the whole thing goes
towards him with my
body here okay thank you Mora okay so as
you come
around you're going to go through those
mechanics okay and that's all you have
don't get greedy and start like using
your waist and stuff if this thing if
this thing is not here with the
imperceptible Motion in an admin it's
don't go for it okay so let's say I'll
take all the slack out there I am and
now what I'll do is I'll change this to
and you didn't tap I'll change it to an
elbow attack so I'll just come back a
little bit and I'm going to crank the
wrist around the elbow and the elbow
around the
wrist okay so the first one is katame
you're doing you're doing that thing and
this one you're turning
here so first though take it all all the
way to where you think that okay that's
kame without you violating good form and
then from there change it and now you do
the elbow
okay don't keep struggling to get a lock
that's not going to work and you have to
compromised position to get it okay so
shoulder not working drop down to the
Elbow tactically you're your order of
priority goes to the shoulder because
you get to work the ground you get more
mechanic iCal Advantage okay but
sometimes you can't like I I'm going to
if we go back when I make him fall this
way and he he ends up most people will
lean on you so they don't fall on you
and so that's why when you go out from
under them they'll fall on the ground
but every once in a while someone won't
so he'll be really adamant on that post
there do you see and he won't let his
shoulder go down well okay take it as
far as you can on katame can't get it
then you come here and you tack the
elbow okay that is another way very
common on why K failed okay so we'll set
that up this time so try your best to
keep your ground your shoulder from
being grounded okay go as far as you can
into katakat and then you would do the
elbow attack instead all right here we
go
he
goes taking my arm that I'm already
sticking to
it pull it
out okay I'll go to different stages
pull it out I don't have it yet my hands
are open okay coming around pull it
out pull it out pull it out pull it out
pull it pull it out pull it out push it
out pull it
out pull it out pull it
out pull it out I'll do each
pin cut a pull it out pull it
out
elbow got it you guys see that okay pull
it out
pull it out pull it out pull it
out pull it
out okay so this is the stick and follow
okay um they're going to be moving
around do you get it okay so we're going
to go up to the wrist now cuz that's the
the hierarchy there shoulder elbow wrist
wrist elbow shoulder okay but if you're
going to keep letting go of everything
you won't be able to do those
Transitions okay so now we go up to the
wrist okay